en las urnas no en las Cortes era el
lema que marcaban muchas de las
pancartas en la manifestación que se
extendió por ciudad de Guatemala el
sábado una que buscaba exigir que las
autoridades del país respeten los
resultados de los comicios celebrados el
pasado 25 de junio
bueno los resultados y que se respeta la
democracia participativa del pueblo ya
hizo manifestarse en las urnas del
pasado 25 de Julio
el núcleo de la manifestación terminó
frente al tribunal supremo electoral
allí los manifestantes pidieron
confirmar la validez de los resultados
que se encuentran suspendidos Desde que
la corte constitucional emitió una
resolución que pedía una revisión
tenemos que defender los votos porque
nosotros fuimos a las urnas a votar no
las acepté él no tiene cinco pelones que
estén ahí no pueden mandar al pueblo de
Guatemala en la primera vuelta de los
comicios Sandra Torres ex primera dama y
candidata de Centro derecha consiguió
15,8% de los votos mientras que de
manera sorpresiva el social demócrata
Bernardo Arévalo se quedó con cerca del
12% de los sufragios los dos se
enfrentarían en una segunda vuelta pero
los resultados Siguen sin hacer su
oficiales la presidenta de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia anunció una nueva
suspensión tras pedir al organismo un
informe sobre Cómo llegó a cabo el
proceso